la france est-elle homophobe c'est notre
question du jour vos réponses
personnellement je pense pas
parce que l'on connaît on a dans nos
tentes fragiles des personnes
homosexuelles ça nous pose aucun
problème et en l'air de bien le vivre
donc
voilà c'est plus arrêter les housses
sacs roussil ici est né il ya des effets
de masse qui sont faits il ya des
manifestations mais bon je suis pas
persuadé que la france soit homophobes
pour ma part non mais après quand ça et
quand on entend ce qui se passe et ce
qui se dit aux informations on est en
lieu de se poser la question mais oui
parce que je trouve que j'ai pas les
gens sont pas tolérants
et ça je trouve que c'est vraiment
catastrophique pourtant pourraient tous
bien vivre ensemble je pense que ça
dépend des personnes je veux pas
généraliser comme ça à l'échelle d'un
pays je dirais que oui
parce que j'ai des amis qui sont dans ce
cas là et qui subissent tous les jours
donc c'est important d'en parler et
c'est important de faire comprendre que
ces personnes sont exactement comme les
autres
vous avez entendu dans les témoignages
qui nous explique que tous les jours des
personnes homosexuelles sont victimes
justement d'actes homophobes selon sos
homophobie les actes homophobes ont
grimpé de 27% par rapport à l'année
précédente l'association qui affirme
avoir reçu
1977 appel en 2012 sur sa ligne d'écouté
trois fois plus de cas d'homophobie et
ce qui se dit donc en prévision c'est
effectivement qu'on a aujourd'hui donc
atteint déjà les scores de 2012 et qu'on
s'oriente sur six fois plus d'actes
homophobes en 2013 c'est juste
inquiétant moi je dis aussi aux gens qui
font les manifs pour tous
ces bien pensants qui continuent de
manifester que parmi leurs enfants il y
as forcément des homosexuels et qu'
heureusement je ne suis pas né dans une
famille homophobes et je m'en réjouis
parce que je plains ces enfants qui
effectivement ne pourront pas dire et ne
pourront pas vivre leur homosexualité
parce qu'ils auront des enfants des
parents qui les auront amené à la manif
pour tous voilà je trouve ça juste
effectivement désolant ça ça aujourd'hui
voulait recentrer ses actes homophobes
ces attitudes gelé toujours ressenti ça
devient de plus en plus lourd à porter
ça se caractérise comme par exemple les
regards des réflexions des remarques sa
marque 0-1 des réflexions des uns et des
autres même si ces deux là dans le ton
de la plaisanterie c'est que ça devient
lourd
c'est ce soit qu'un jour on trouvera
autre chose mais c'est ainsi ça puisse
avec le mariage pour tous ça rajouter
une couche quand vous renvoie une image
la différence en fait oui parce qu'on
est tous différent en tant que gay on
est tous différent en tant qu'
hétérosexuels on est on est tous
différents mais on nous accepte pas
parce qu'on nous fait une stigmatisation
ils ne les connaissent pas ils veulent
pas les connaître on est tout à fait
normal on discute on parle de tout et de
rien je vois pas où est ce que qu'on est
différent vous êtes arrivé en france à
sept ans de russie dans une famille
d'adoption et 14 ans vous leur annoncer
que vous êtes homosexuel ça se passe pas
bien et vous couper les ponts avec eux
comment ça s'est passé le moment de
cette annonce quand vous avez révélé à
votre famille d'adoption que vous étiez
homosexuels
le regard du père adoptif a changé et
l'ailleurs regard noir profond
et la mère adoptive d'un côté
c'est de même c'est comme si elle
n'avait plus de fils mais deux mois de
toute façon j'avais plus de parents ce
qu'ils m'ont fait subir
davantage avance plus ça ça fait
vraiment beaucoup à supporter
maltraitance physique maltraitance
mentale ça c'était avant déjà de leur
annoncer qu'elle était homosexuelle il
ya de ça avant mais 14 ans ava que
l'état m'a sauvé un petit peu de chez
eux
sinon c'est soit je mourrai si
si je serais restée là bas
l'un d'un côté j'étais sauvé j'ai fait
des familles d'accueil foyer l'incertain
familles d'accueil dans toutes les
familles d'accueil ça passer mon
homosexualité dans les foyers il fallait
avoir un une stature il fallait ce pas
être hétérosexuel
car ça s'est compliqué avoue faisait
comme si vous étiez hétérosexuels au
quotidien vous cachiez cette
homosexualité lorsque vous êtes ensuite
à l'épée de foyer en foyer oui parce que
j'ai perdu toute l'éducation qui me
fallait parce qu'il manque toujours pas
mal et que j'apprends chaque jour pour
rattraper tout mon passé et à cause de
ça bon bah je vais d des conneries j'ai
failli me suicide à cause de ça parce
que je ne savais plus comment m'en
sortir
le monde d'avoir une famille c'est
constant ce n'est pas supportable parce
que l'homophobie ce qu'ils m'ont fait
subir
je l' ai toujours en moi et je ne sais
toujours pas comment mon c'est pareil
c'est l'association le refuge ensuite
oui vous a aidé qui vous a relancé par
la suite association qui a fêté ses 10
ans comment vous êtes c'est rentrer en
contact avec eux et vous ont ils et de
quelle manière
je suis pris contact avec un des
responsables du refuge ils m'ont aidé
ils m'ont trouvé un hôtel pour ne pas
que je vive dehors que je fasse
un travail pas pas très catholique pour
s'en sortir pour le nourrir et même être
dehors de survivre contre l'homophobie
il fallait avoir encore davantage une
autre stature être agressif se protéger
sans cesse du regard des autres
les juges aient davantage
et ils m'ont aidé à faire des cv ils
m'ont tous fait avoir des nouveaux
papiers et grâce à lui j'ai trouvé un
travail où je me sens de mieux en mieux
ces temps ci mais c'est toujours pas
gagné parce que digérer tout ça est ce
que j'entends assez de suite ça devient
de plus en plus lourd
là où je travaille ça ça commence à
apaiser
80 le témoignage de sacha on voit qu'il
ya des blessures qui sont profondément
ancrées quand on écoute sans son
parcours ils sont nombreux ces jeunes
aussi avoir eu des difficultés aussi à
révéler leur homosexualité à la vie vaut
au niveau de modestie on a monté une
structure qui s'appelle hf égalité qui a
fait donc des spots de prévention et de
promotion donc de l'égalité notamment
sur l'homophobie on a été les premiers à
dénoncer bien avant leur fut d'ailleurs
en 2004 on a dénoncé le fait que le
premier vecteur d'homophobie en france
est effectivement le vecteur de
l'homophobie dans le cercle familial
c'est extrêmement destructeur parce que
on a énormément de jeunes qui se
découvre homosexuel qui ne peuvent pas
le dire à leurs parents parce qu'ils
sentent que leurs parents sont
homophobes et on a donc des jeunes qui
vont effectivement aller beaucoup plus
vers le suicide et qui vont donc faire
des fûts voire même être viré de chez
leurs parents ni plus ni moins ça c'est
le vrai visage de l'homophobie en france
vous avez le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui ça
va s'aggraver ce genre de situation ça
leasing déjà en train de s'aggraver
c'est à dire que nous on collabore au
niveau de nos festi et d'achat fidélité
beaucoup avec eux le refuge hachette
prévention d'ailleurs embauche des
jeunes du refuge aussi pour les
professionnaliser et on se rend bien
compte qu'il y a de plus en plus de
jeunes qui viennent donc au refuge et de
moins en moins de moyens vis-à-vis donc
de l'état parce que l'état n'est plus en
capacité de supporter cette vague de
mots phobie il faut bien imaginer que
nous étions dans un dans une france qui
était tolérante vis-à-vis des
homosexuels
nous avions le pacs ça fonctionnait
plutôt pas mal le fait que le mariage
pour tous ne soient pas acceptés à
monter effectivement les choses en
épingle et aujourd'hui on nous avons
énormément de personnes qui sont
homophobes et énormément de parents qui
rejettent leurs enfants parce
qu'effectivement ils se sentent permis
de pouvoir le faire aujourd'hui en
france alors autour de ces questions
d'homophobie forcément nous avons aussi
posé la question à l'un des
organisateurs sur saint quentin en
yvelines dans le département des
yvelines de ces manifs pour tous at il
le sentiment d'avoir justement ouvert
7/7 boîte de pandore d'avoir un mis le
doigt dans renage de l'homophobie voici
sa réponse c'était ce week end propos
recueillis par elodie moines je ne pense
pas que il était bondé promulguer cette
loi le jour de la lutte contre
l'homophobie pourquoi parce que ça ait
signé le notre combat un combat
homophobes or vous pouvez le constater
il n'y a jamais eu de casse il n'y a
jamais eu d'attaqués physiques contre
qui que ce soit lors de nos
manifestations c'est un combat
anthropologique que nous menons
homophobe c'est la réponse de mathieu
colombani crédibilisation sans le départ
et sont connues manille est adorable et
très gentil mais à un moment donné c'est
ce que lui dit c'est pas la réalité de
ce qui se passe la réalité et on l'a vu
dans tous les journaux télé y compris
les journaux nationaux il ya des
casseurs il ya des gens qui sont
effectivement très homophobe on a des
gens qui sont profondément extrême
droite on a des gens qui effectivement
donc en voie des menaces de mort le les
sites d'achève prévention dom au festi
d'achat l'égalité on était ni plus ni
moins attaquer donc de l'extérieur on
s'est retrouvé avec de nombreux sites de
la communauté gay qui ont effectivement
été attaqués mois le même j'ai reçu
effectivement des menaces à un moment
donné stop la loi était promulguée ils
sont pas obligés on leur enlève heure
rien n'y a pas de droits qui sont
enlevés et je rappelle quand même parce
que c'est important de rappeler que
l'homophobie c'est condamnable c'est un
délit et c'est un délit et c'est en
l'occurrence 45000 euros d'amendé et
trois ans de prison moi je souhaite
vivement que ce gouvernement qui a
permis d'avoir la le mariage pour tous
et donc plus d'égalité face vraiment
respecter cette loi parce qu'à un moment
donné on ne peut plus avoir des gens qui
font tout et n'importe quoi on ne peut
plus avoir des agressions homophobes en
clair justement qui régnait lors des
prochains mariages gays qui vont être
célébré il ya des débordements c'est
évident c'est évident que radio c'est
parce qu'en nous est égal est du racisme
la havane
ce n'est plus c'est de l'homophobie mais
c'est égal à du racisme comme si on
était
soit du maghreb dans notre pays c'est
égal à 100 et c'est un délit vous l'avez
rappelé c'est un délit alors moi ce que
ce que j'aimerais aussi dit c'est que on
ne leur avait retiré ça n'est qu'une
extension de droit et en l'occurrence ça
continuer à être dans ce dans ce
schéma-là et mathieu montmagny est
encore en visible en dans ce schéma là
ça me rassure que dans 50 ans ni ligne
est plus que dix voitures sauf que
effectivement mois dans le train
aujourd'hui je ne peux plus avoir de
conversation comme je pouvais les avoir
avant parce que les gens ont de la
suspicion regarde de travers voir jette
des réflexions donc à la tête et ça
devient pesant et je dis aussi une
dernière chose pour conclure c'est que
la région ile de france a bien pris le
poids donc des problèmes qu'il y a en
l'occurrence en ile de france et
souhaite monter à terme une campagne de
lutte contre l'homophobie qui devrait
sortir probablement la proche donc de la
lesbian gay pride qui sera le dernier
week-end de juin où on pourra encore ces
mesures et le mariage pour tous cas on
aura l'occasion d'asseoir d'en reparler
merci à vous êtes revenu sur le plateau
n'est pas encore aussi à sacha pour ce
témoignage la suite de cette suite ce
soir ce sera avec du sport de
l'environnement mais tout de suite de la
politique